and uh looks like i might survive it
after all in fact i'm quite thrilled to
see that there's there's still um
almost 70 people here that have stuck it
out to the end i was
i i was expecting to come with the the
final devoted dozen or something
to this last hour
but now it looks like i'm going to
actually have to give the lecture
okay several things happened in between
first of all we had an overwhelming vote
for
um changing dvi uh with respect to these
xxx commands so now the official dvi
version two has xxx1
xx2 x6x3 xxx4
uh and the postamble instruction is
number 243 now
and
so that is going to take place uh uh
don't uh
propagate this old this old uh
definition of version two too far
because that's just has a bug in it you
know this cover
cover to the guinea pig edition says
that it has bugs in it and nothing has
been announced as version one yet or
anything so
uh we can still make these changes
uh the official version too we'll have
that in it for sure
another thing i could i guess i should
have mentioned last hour is the
i see there were several things that
came up people
commented on one is that uh a good idea
for having these
these pointers in there that's that that
connect uh one blp to the previous one
is that you can skip around and just
print a few pages of the file and that's
that's quite often people uh
have a huge dvi file and they say please
uh something the paper wrinkled on on
page 98 or something or you know would
you please just give me page 98 again
and this makes it a fast way to skip
through the file for such things like
that if you can
um now on the other hand on ibm pascal
it won't allow you to go uh conveniently
from the end of the file and they and
they have been uh
writing two post animals they write the
ordinary dvi file
and then they also write the post gamble
as a separate file and uh it's easy and
on their particular system it's just as
well for them to pick up the post amble
first from this short file and then read
the other one and keep two files uh
in tandem like that
but if they want to ship a dvi file
somewhere else they've got to have it in
the standard format
with the post emble at the end
question
uh that's not necessary in the ibm vm
system you just need the one class not
necessarily it's a matter of preference
in some places that they might want to
do it but they might yeah okay that's
true it's uh
um okay thanks roger uh
maybe would be a good idea for dvi type
to be called version two since it prints
out version two dvi files
uh-huh
well that's a thought
now the uh
uh let's see
it was probably something else that i
forgot about that i forgot i thought it
would be a good idea to bring out um hmm
what was it
oh well
there's a million things that i wish i
could present to you all but it's time
is so short
now
the subject of this last lecture was
announced as getting and initializing a
working tech production system and we
want to talk about that first and then
clean up with all all other questions
answered so the the um
as i mentioned several times we've got
a switch in the program
code that's between
init and
teeny is
uh
oh is is commented out unless you're
you're writing a program
unless you're generating a version of
text called any text
then
if you have um
so if this really
is null
if if these are both null then you get
any tech if these are our brackets
um and in order to get it to come out in
web you you put uh escape character in
front of it to get to get the brackets
then you get a program that's called
virtex beertech or
vertex or
virgin tech it's a
something it's a version of tech that is
for production doesn't have anything in
it
it's a tabula rasa it's it's mind is
clean has no
no
nothing
inside of it
now
the uh
the only difference
then is what is how you set in it in
tiny in order to generate these two you
should you should probably make
different uh change files
um that differ only
in a few ways
but one of them to generate this one i
want to generate this one unless you
would prefer to
edit that you know maybe one of them you
you're generating um you know you you
keep your change file in one form and
then edit it back and forth and write a
little program to fix that or something
but
since we don't we don't have nested
change files in our web system uh we
don't have a way to make it a
shortchange file in your big change file
so i've been just keeping two change
files and i don't change only these two
things
in i also change the sizes of of tables
in my initech i don't have this larger
mem size
because i don't need it i only need
enough to read in my macros not to
actually use the macros
in
any tech however i increase the size of
my hyphenation tables because i don't
know how many
how many uh patterns i'll actually need
and then in in vertex uh i'll i'll know
um you know from looking at different
format packages i'll i'll uh know that i
have enough room if i cut cut the
hyphenation tables down now any tech can
do a few things that vertex can't
it can write format files
it can load all the primitives into the
hash table you can load all the strings
into the string pool it
it can
compute pattern
take patterns and pack them into this
pack try that we talked about yesterday
those algorithms are commented out
otherwise and they would just be
deadwood in in a production version of
tech because they only have to be done
on these rare occasions when somebody is
loading in a brand new format package
that's supposed to be uh that's supposed
to be dumped out now
um
in order to make room for those then you
can you can
decrease the mem size but on the
production version detect well let the
mem size be as large as
as reasonable so that you can
you know set larger jobs
i
i actually don't imagine that at sale
we'll actually be using either these
programs very often because what will
happen is when you when you run vertex
then
you will say
uh some format that you will load say
amps tech but let's say
for first basic
and you will and you will ask for vertex
basic here i'm showing it as a command
line i'll talk about command lines later
so vertex suppose i run vertex and it
gives me a prompt and i say basic
and then
it runs through the basic file and then
i say dump
oh no vertex no sorry
let me talk any tech first
all right i'm getting ahead of myself
here in attack
two asterisks
and i start out and
and uh i say basic unit tech then reads
in basic format
basic loads in a lot of fonts it defines
patterns for hyphenation
it
defines a bunch of macros it defines
your codes math codes dell codes uc
codes sf codes
you know for the math codes tell what
characters mean in math mode
sf codes are the space factor uh uh
settings
um
the uh
the the uh
macros are going to
are going to be keyed to certain fonts
in there so they'll they'll work well
with fonts they'll say that your math
greetings from seattle
i just got the note here saying
greetings from seattle i don't know what
that says but uh excuse me a minute
um
i don't know if phyllis knew that she
was interrupting this class yeah well
um the the delimiter codes
oh goodness forget it
uh
okay the the delimiter codes um would be
tied to your fonts so for example let's
say that you left parenthesis
it says that your left parenthesis is um
uh in a certain position in the font so
that you can start your searching for
next larger and things like that
now um
the
the guy went
to college with me
lives in hong kong he's a he was a
professor of mathematics at ohio at iowa
state for several years but now he's
decided to be rich instead
okay now that's that no
okay
um
some
computer mail uh is is so easy to send
you get a lot of it and so i've had my
secretary screen it for me but uh
sometimes uh
she doesn't know if i really want an
urgent message or not
basic will contain all that stuff and so
i haven't written basic yet but you can
see what that that it will have to have
everything that that
depends on the fonts is going to be is
going to be in there it used to be pre
it used to be predefined in tech in the
present tech uh i'm embarrassed to say
this but uh
there was a there was a relationship
between the kinds of of
uh delimiters that you had to have in
different fonts the left bracket the
the the left bracket and the floor
functions and so on in the symbols font
had to be in exactly the same position
in the extension font except shift it
over
and that was ridiculous but it was you
know at the time i designed that
i thought i was going to be the only
user of the program
now now all these things are freed up
and they're all specified by tables
basic is where those tables appear so
that
anybody who
uses uh
the basic that i supply that'll be
geared to the the fonts that i supply
also just to be consistent somebody has
another guy's fonts they make their own
their their own uh
analog of basic okay run any tech and
then it asks for basic and then after
that it might prompt us for the next
thing and we'll say dump
dump prints out
now it will then print out a bunch of
messages saying that it's printing out
plot
file basic fmt and it's going to be
called basic fmt and then the date
today's date so
when when um uh tech starts out it would
have said uh this is tech any tech
version something any tech and then when
this one starts out it will say this is
tech uh
uh
and no format pre-loaded
and then we would
say basic and it would use the algorithm
i mentioned earlier today to bring in
this file basic.fmt
and it would then have um all that stuff
all the fonts and everything done
now on our system uh this would save a
great deal of time because
uh this will mention about 20 fonts
i think and uh to open 20 different
short tfm files and read them in takes a
bunch of time on our system um reading
one fmt file be much faster
uh the time actually to generate to
enter all those primitives in the hash
table is negligible that was taking
was was quite fast 240 calls on the hash
program that wasn't too bad to uh
compute the patterns was taking about
eight seconds
according to the patterns that we showed
yesterday so that wasn't too bad but
really but so the the thing we're really
saving oh well we wouldn't want to do
those eight seconds every time but we're
saving uh maybe 15 seconds for loading
those tfm files and i don't know why but
uh
it's when the time sharing uh uh decides
to
give service to the other people when
we've got when we're opening a lot of
short files on our system anyway
now vertec is there then and and if you
say basic then you're then then you got
it the way the program is set up if you
didn't say basic you would get basic
uh because basic is the default but
imagine that this was some other thing
besides basic
now on most uh on on on anyway
on lucky systems let's say you can now
save the whole core image
and start from here
and and and imagine a uh
you know so you hit call or something
here and source a and then you say save
the core image
and um
our operating system is is able to swap
you out at this point
and and uh timeshare uh for other things
on a lot of computers so then it should
be able to swap you in again tomorrow uh
and over and over again for each user uh
the capability is pretty pretty much in
there uh the
the thing that the operating system uh
worries about is uh your registers
getting them in a consistent state or
something like that but there's there's
um
if you're lucky there's a system that
call it you can make that will put this
out on some
dump file or xe file or some other kind
of called file that that you can load
directly and uh it's even faster to load
this than to go through your linking
loader it takes disks
it's fast and we don't even have to read
in
the font file now
if so if you have that then you should
then you could save it and call it tech
because the word tech itself
will be used in the user manual to
indicate a
a version that that assumes basic format
my user manual is going to be an
introduction to the primitives of tech
as extended by basic format and there
will be a distinction between what's
primitive and what's in in basic
but
it's not going to introduce anybody
else's format module but you can't use
tech without a format module very well
so it
basic is the one that it's going to talk
about
now so that's the system we'll call tech
um if this instead of basic was say
uh ampstech
for the american mass society or
whatever
macro package you have then we would
save that and we would have amps tech
and somebody then
who starts out and so that's why i'm
saying any type of vertex hardly ever
would be called people the users out
there would be
running tech or amstec or whatever the
the popular format
things are at your place
um
uh
that would certainly that would that
would be uh of some advantage uh uh
just because they have less det type it
saves them a little bit but in our on
our system anyway we would probably do
it that way
not it's not going to be true for
everybody's system
now how what's going to happen inside
this pascal program so that the pascal
program knows what to do at this point
because the pascal program doesn't just
want to start out from this core image
at this point that would actually be a
mistake
it has a date and time recorded in there
for example
that's no good it's got
a job name already recorded in it amps
tech
you would your job name would always
come out called amps on amster
dvi
so there are things that you want to
initialize over again
when you start running okay well that's
been
explained in the program
when we get down to
the main program which is uh
there at
51 module number 1197
and i'm going through the discussion
here that's in 1198. the
there's a global variable that i call
ready already
and this is initialized
to
when when tech get when
when any of these programs start out
and and set
the key global variables to values
then ready already gets set to a sort of
a strange constant 314159
under the assumption that it's very
unlikely that it already uh was happened
to be that
when the when the loader finished with
the program
now um
some pascals will
will be cautious and they will put a
special flag value into variables so
that if you make the mistake of using a
variable before you have
assigned it a value
then it gives you an error message and
if you
if you uh so that would destroy this
because i've i am using
uh breaking the rules of pascal the very
first thing i do
after opening the terminal for output is
ask if ready already equals three one
four one five nine
if it does then i assume everything is
okay
and i jump it right into uh the
beginning of the program otherwise i go
through the whole initialization
procedure that will do prompting and
things like this for format files
now
these systems that protect you against
such sins
also probably they allow you to turn off
this protection
and
as soon as tech is debugged we won't
need that protection anymore so that so
you would be able to turn it off and
still use this kind of a
hack but this is a way that works on a
lot of systems so all i have to do is
is save it uh with the global variables
um including ready already uh equal to
this constant and then there's a small
chance that that the constant already
would have been there uh just by
coincidence from some previous tech run
that it got loaded in the same place and
the loader hadn't cleared it out i
suppose
but that's that's the chance that i'm
taking now
okay now uh
oh i explained
i explained all of that and uh
what else is there to talk about for
initializing
any questions on this
would say that i would say the major
part of the debugging that i've done has
been in in arranging these uh things at
the very beginning and and uh end of the
program so that they
so that they will handle
unusual exceptional cases that i didn't
think of when i first wrote the program
uh the the ins the guts of the thing
inside where it's doing syntax and
semantics and so on that's all clean
computer science and this other stuff is
is hard
and uh
and i think it's getting close to being
correct
um
okay now
there's one thing that any tech can't do
and that is load a format file
any tech always um
it i guess it has to load the string
file the string pool and and there's no
easy way for me to tell it that
i wanted to load a format file instead
and start from there so i just didn't
build that in
um
i have to fake it now as i'm debugging
the thing i stop it with the debugger at
the point where it tests if format
identity equals zero
and i and format ident is a variable
inside the program
that um any text
initializes
in any there's there's the assignment
format ident is set to quote any text
uh in in parenthesis i guess
and otherwise it's a variable that's set
to zero
and then
any tech sets it to the name of the
format after preloading a format like
it'll say basic
of july 28 1982 or something like that
so format ident is uh
um is set non-zero at this first part of
the program only if i've got any tech
and uh so so in order to bypass that i
stop my debugger at this line
where it's going to test format ident
for zero and i i reset format ident to
zero using the debugger ability to set
variables and then it goes through and i
and i pretend i have a
vertex for debugging
but uh
it has to be done with change files
otherwise and i i guess that's okay i
don't see that i ought to have a special
test in there but i might think of
something that that improves that by the
time this thing finally gets released
since since otherwise any tech can do
everything um the code is there to load
the format file there's just no way to
get to it unless i unless i change
format ident manually
so that's the way i've been doing it as
i as i get the thing started now
okay i think i've covered the main
points that i wanted to make and uh so i
open up for all other questions answered
and if these questions want to focus on
another part of the of the tech program
then i can try to answer questions on
that
arthur can you use uh dump with vertec
if you say dump with vertec it
you get into error message
shown in module 1190
where is it okay dump and end come out
with the same command code
and so as far as most of tech is
concerned end and dump are treated
identically until you get to
a
module where
okay
module 1203 right
and that and c is set to kerchar this is
the final cleanup procedure is what's
called at the very end
and uh c is the uh
kercher which is either zero or one if
it was end or dump
um at this point it checks to see
whether you've had it you've uh
you have a name for your for your uh log
file or whatever it will be called
and uh interesting algorithm therefore
to eject the remaining pages i guess i
ought to talk about that a second
uh and then
it you check to see whether or not we've
we've finished all the groups that we
were in
um
uh but then there's this test if c
equals one
then uh in init we will do store format
file and return but if that's commented
out we get to this error message that
says uh
uh you lose um i mean it's just another
thing in parenthesis that that can
happen at the end everything else goes
on the same so it ends but it doesn't
dump
and that's because there's a heck of a
lot of code uh just for dumping
the these files
uh it's uh
it was uh uh starts on module 1167
and the dumping and undumping are
presented in parallel first you have a
dump module and then you have an
undumped one that's it to load it again
and you can see the parallelism between
those but but the uh we sort the uh
we sort the available space list
and uh do various things like that that
uh
that we just soon have commented out in
the
in the uh production version of tech
now this this what happens when you end
that something there's a there's an end
game um i've heard a lot of people who
have lost pages you know they they they
had a
figure that was carried over to another
page
and uh at the end of their job and they
and uh they never got to see that page
somehow it ended in uh their typesetting
system forgot about that one it was
floating to his floating insertion and
it got floated all the way out to the
end
and uh um i and it's possible in tech
you see the right general output
routines that
that
absorb information but don't print it
and
and then they might change to another
output routine and all kinds of things
can happen so what are we supposed to do
with something like this how are we
going to know that the output routine
hasn't been stashing away this
information for some future thing well
what i do actually um is in module 1204
there
so i called b build page which which
which
is a procedure that that
gets it empties everything out that's
already been contributed uh to the first
page
uh and calls the output routine if um
if it's time to do so
one of the things that would cause it to
do that is if there's a
uh
a forced page break a penalty of
negative 10 000 or less
is a would would cause the uh cause a
ship out to occur
uh
however ship out doesn't occur on empty
pages
now
i mean output routine to get fired up
except on empty pages well then
i check and see if page head is equal to
page tail in which case i'm happy now
page head and page tail that that says
how much is is there anything left on
the current page
if not then i figure i'm done
so the output routine then
didn't leave any residue
and
and i figure i'm done otherwise i put in
a null box
and i contribute a null box whose width
is the h size
and i then i put on eject penalty a
force break penalty
and i do that up to 25 times until i get
until finally the output routine has
ended
with um
with nothing there
i hope that works if that doesn't work
i'll have to think of something
uh
some something else but i book but uh
with luck that will work and get the
last page out anyway
right now i propose that that's really
going to be the definition of how of of
the end game for finishing up a tech job
if i just put out a penalty
all by itself then it wouldn't
necessarily invoke the output routine
but by putting out a
box followed by this eject penalty
then i am sure to invoke the output
routine because putting out a box starts
out the page and says that the top
baseline skip is put on there and all
the other things that that
the page is not empty it's guaranteed to
to invoke an output routine
if i just made that box
null box then i would get an output
routine that has
that has a column width of zero
and this this has has led to bad results
when your output routine is trying to
build up five columns of stuff and uh
and you give it a couple of null boxes
and so then these two columns stretch
out uh
over uh because you've got null box over
here instead of being the right width so
i make this box that i put out there i
make this box have the correct width
but i i make i think i have the wrong
test here because i used because i
should really not just page head equals
page tail i should also check that
something was shipped out
um
uh because it because i uh it's possible
the output routine would have absorbed
something and not shipped it out so i
i'm going to make this know i'm going to
make this a little more complicated in
order to fix that
yeah that's right
nothing like trying to explain something
to somebody in order to realize that
it's not working
question what happens if you make an
insert several inserts to the same box
they all get concatenated together until
one of them has to split and then future
ones are are bypassed and carried over
to the future
that code has been fairly well checked
out that's what i spent most of my time
on debugging and that's in the two two
parts called uh
breaking breaking vertical lists into
pages and the previous one is um
let's see
breaking vertical list in the pages is
part 43 and then the page builder is
part 44 and those uh it spells that out
in some detail but it's a comp this this
is what i call the researchy part of
tech and
and uh uh i think it's in it's it
doesn't fairly tight shape here i
haven't debugged the paragraph builder
yet at the present time but uh
but this part of the page builder i have
gotten
i think correct um
arthur
uh what happens if your output routine
just takes whatever it gets in boxes to
b5 and ships it out
will your
check the remaining pages just keep on
spewing out paper
no
it only it only does that you see a ship
out would only occur on an empty
on on an empty box and uh
i see i i would want to also turn turn
that off yeah
yeah i got to find a good a good
termination condition for this
it worked fairly well in the present
text so all i have to do is convert that
to
to this one
it was similar but
not the same so i better do that again i
remember going around
about six times on the present tech too
to get that to work
multi-column output
the problem is if you're saying putting
five columns on a page then
in your output routine goes has five
steps to it
and uh and so you finished the second
column and then
end came along what are you going to do
and you want to give the output routine
uh
something to do for
until it reaches a state where it
actually does a ship out
then i think we're done
maybe
unless it gives you no and then it might
put something back on the contribution
list which would mean that we it still
wants to be invoked again
but let's not solve that problem online
is there a question on that side of the
house
somebody said what about the
availability of these tapes these tapes
are going to be rented i suppose
just like the previous tech classes were
done and i'm going to try to get two
copies
of these tapes
one to be kept at stanford one to be
kept in providence
will be the possession they'll be the
property of the tech users group
uh please use your mic
but i don't like that kind of question
how long do i expect before x is these
kind of questions are forboden i mean
as soon as i can as soon as i can as
soon as i can
i'm having a vacation though too i'm
going to collapse tonight
yeah uh you were going to mention
something about uh rounding on low
resolution devices ah yes rounding on
low resolution devices yeah good thing
um we want to uh
um
after
after looking at uh at this problem for
some time and discussion we think we
have a fairly good solution to uh the
question of how to
how to
make reasonably high quality
on low resolution without uh
and and
and and still at high resolution now you
have a problem um
that uh
i could say this way suppose we have a
10 point font my original 10 point font
was uh was working on the xtp printer
who had had a nice feature exactly two
pixels per unit in the font so that so
they were 36 pixels in a in a quad
and
all of the widths were based on monotype
uh widths so they were integer number of
units and so everything in my 10 point
font was an integer number of pixels
the n would be
10 unit character so it'd be 20 pixels
wide
now
what about nine point then that meant
that each of the each of the units in
nine point font was 1.8 pixels wide
and so i'd be setting uh a word
uh whatever the you know like what's
your favorite word w-o-r-d
and um
um
the uh
and my original implementation the very
first one of tech i i rounded for every
character
so i computed the exact position where
the character should start
and then i rounded so that
this nine points would eventually uh
get the street you know
it would be a build up
and all of a sudden we'd go back one
pixel wherever that would happen to have
have happened to happen and so if word
would occur here a little bit to the
right
the glitch of where the uh thing shifts
would take place at still in at yet
another place
um
now that wasn't too satisfactory but we
didn't mind because uh we used mostly 10
point type and this was just for proof
quality anyway but then we started to
see that people actually had low
resolution devices they wanted to send
out on their on their letterhead they
were using this for correspondence and
everything it was supposed to actually
look look fairly reasonable even though
it was you know coming out of a low
resolution device
and then we said well uh
okay a font designer can tune the design
of letters so that
each character is width is a is a
integer number of pixels
um
but then uh it's not machine dependent
it's not machine independent because if
you write the tfm file it's and it's
only good on a on a machine that has a
pixel width of uh of a certain kind
uh then it's then
how should you have the same font on
another photo typesetter so what's a
good solution to have having your cake
and eating it too it seemed that that
seems now we can actually do this fairly
well
meanwhile we noticed that there were
that there were people writing dvi
drivers here that didn't know how i had
rounded every character and they decided
that they were don't they they were
going to uh only round at the beginning
of the of the of a word
and uh that start that that looked
pretty good you see they wherever you
started then you would use the pixel
width of the character
and continue along uh with the pixel
width until you got to a new
a new h skip or something that would
take you there so this was doing this
this meant that the font designer even
though the tfm file had true machine
independent uh
widths in it
the pixel the
font designer could also tune it so that
it would the sidebars would be nice for
the spacing of the letters in a word
now in tech we have we have kerning in
order to improve the quality of the
output so
um
uh i i don't know i think maybe between
r and d there's a current i'm not sure
but let's suppose for the sake of
argument w and o i'm sure there is
there's a little current that brings a w
and o a little closer uh because like
i'm pretty sure at w because x and y do
and so a half a unit uh closer spacing
is is is there in the uh in the dvi file
so so between the set w and the set o
command there's a
uh
uh you know a write by minus
a few uh
in the dvi file
um
which brings the letters a little closer
this meant that these algorithms that
were that were uh
starting at the beginning and going and
then only doing a correction after glue
would make this correction at the point
of a current
so we'd be setting along a 10-letter
word and if we have a current right
there then um
um there would actually be a
recalculation and the rounding error
would be uh
uh
the glitch would occur at this point
well as a result currents were causing
the quality of the output to get worse
instead of better
they were intended there to to make
refinements that would help but actually
they were causing the rounding to to
occur at that point and spoiling it all
well
we don't want to take the kerns out of
the of the formal font definition we
want to use exactly the same tfm
so that our lines will break the same uh
when we're printing on the high
resolution device we we want tech to do
all the calculations the same so what's
the answer on the dvi file and the
answer is that we
we round um
after we make a large jump
in horizontal or vertical direction then
we round otherwise we do all our
calculations relatively
so the uh
the font um
so so when we're not making a a a large
skip and large skip is defined as a
certain percentage of the current m in
the font i think it was
then then we will just stick with pixel
widths that are that that come either in
the pixel file or that we could get by
rounding the character with to um
uh to an integer now the the metaphon
programs have
a char
width
command where you say that what the char
width is in points and this might be w
and then metaphon also has a char device
width command
which is
generally given as round of pixels times
w something like that
in the
typical use of metaphor this is what
we've been doing and and this device
which goes into the pixel file or well
it's used to decide
the width of the characters with its
sidebars
now the actual width of the character
uh we found in in refining fonts we want
to um
uh fiddle with this and not use this
value exactly every time
uh on the letter m for example it turned
out that we if we wanted to get this
distance to be the same as this distance
we would like the m to be one or one
pixel more or one pixel less than uh we
would calculate by taking 15 units and
rounding to uh
to the nearest pixel
so um we could make that kind of
adjustment and then anyway the the width
that's actually there in the character
uh file could be used for the for the
typesetting process
the moral is then
we have a register h and v
for our horizontal and vertical
coordinates in dvi units
uh and as you saw in the printout there
h was large and
so on
um
then we also keep registers hh and vv
and these are kept
in pixels
and updated locally
and only do you set hh to be the rounded
value of h
when you've made a big jump
in and uh in the vertical direction the
problem was not for within a word but
for fractions like one half
uh we wanted one half to the spacing
between here and here to be about the
same no matter where this appeared on
the page and we chose the definition of
a big jump so that
this would not cause big jumps in a
fraction like one half
but but but so that for getting from one
line to the next line would be
considered a big jump
so all the all the vertical spacing in
here is relative
to
something that would be rounded the same
in in no matter where we started from so
vv count so in other words we're taking
calculations like v v is set to
round of v
after big jump
but it's set to v v
um it's set to okay suppose we're doing
a v is set to v plus a
uh then we then if a is large we do bv
set to round to v otherwise we set v v
to v v
plus round of a
around here i'm assuming it includes the
factor for getting to pixels
so here's a relative calculation for
small jumps
and uh a big calculation
and that's where the rounding error
ought to accumulate in the big jumps
because that's where the i isn't going
to see it
so a simple solution but uh took us a
while to find it
now that's that solution is is uh
implemented in the dvi type program that
we that we passed out
as a model for uh how to
how we propose to to do this kind of
type setting
you were mentioning the existence uh
earlier of an allocate function for
things like dimensions and boxes and
things like that is that going to be
part of the basic uh
format
allocating function for dimensions and
boxes i'm sorry
when so that uh if you need a new
dimension oh yeah oh thank you yeah
basic is going to contain
uh something like uh get
font
uh get count get demand
and then it will return to you in is
symbolic it will return to you a uh
a number that hasn't been used before
so that several people can be so if you
want to define a box then you can
that then you can get one i i believe
that it will be a rather simple-minded
macro it's not going to keep
a linked list of the available ones
but
it will probably uh do assume last in
first out if you if you uh
if you are uh take leaving them back in
there again
jan
i just want to say one thing about the
rounding
problem because we faced almost
exactly writing the driver for our
device
well we did almost exactly the same
thing except we would compare the size
of the indicated motion in dvi with the
size of the error that we developed
and we tried we'd pick up the error only
when the size of the indicated motion
was um somewhat larger than the
accumulated error
rather than using a fixed um dimension
saying that if the motion is bigger than
this we'll always pick up the error here
if we compare the two
and so if you accumulated a very large
error over a word you would not
necessarily pick it up all at once
on the next space if that would wipe out
the space
that's interesting you should talk about
that maybe that will work out yeah okay
um
we don't we were hoping that the error
wouldn't uh would never get that large
um
uh that there should we we're assuming
that this uh that the device width
compared to the which would would never
really exceed
uh would never really exceed one pixel
or certainly not two
actually on our machine it turns out you
see one pixel
entirely too well
because we in fact had our first driver
do exactly what you had there with the
kerning
and you didn't currently notice when the
current all of a sudden wasn't there
right
yeah i um i had a
a difficult time
again with that word different no i
guess it was different
but in the tech manual that we printed
on on the dover i was trying to
illustrate the what happens if you'd use
kerning and and not use kerning
with uh with the word
and
and the way it was rounding it was
actually going the wrong way
and uh the uncurrent one was coming so i
had to add a couple extra words of the
text in order to get it in the right
position on the page so that that
doesn't happen
i i
i've never admitted this before
also one other thing
that sort of was curious about this
when uh i first got into this i had a
little i wrote in my driver a little
thing that would send out what is the
error how much different is what tech
thinks the width of the characters and
what the character actually is and i was
using your old computer modern fonts
and i began to get the impression that
you'd tune them for a certain machine
when i was getting half a pixel error on
almost every other character coming
along
almost everything was the worst possible
case
um
yeah okay well uh currents were
you see
yeah see the machine the resolution that
i was assuming in my first design was
252 to the inch which is somewhat close
to yours
and my currents by a half a unit would
be about a half a pixel
yeah
question here what's the status of
debugging on uh dvi type
dvi type
is
it seems to be working but i i just had
dvi file to test it on
as of last saturday
and uh so right now but right now i'm
i'm uh willing to pay a dollar for every
bug
that's for the to the first person who
finds a bug in dvi type uh i'm willing
to i'm willing to uh
pay a dollar for that and uh that'll go
up to two dollars after a few months so
if you really want to hold off and
gamble on it
you could but otherwise you you you
think you've got one you could send it
in and uh
and gratefully update this yes
could you give us an idea of what your
plans are for meta font my plans for
medifont um are just to
do for it as i did with tech um go
make a make a new version uh considering
the what user's experience has been
to
incorporate the
what seems to be better ideas at that
time we're going to experiment with
changing the um
uh changing the the changing a few
things we're going to see if
if conics would work as good as cubic
splines
we're going to experiment with trying to
find intersection between points we're
going to experiment with
with um
well one thing that looks definitely
we're going to do is is make a d draw
with pin of size one to be very very
efficient it's terribly inefficient now
and it seems to be a very important for
lots of kinds of fonts like calligra
calligraphers fonts so
so uh that's
that's going to go in as uh right now uh
d draw is means filling in between two
curves if you have a if you have a pen
that's reasonably wide and you want to
fill in between this curve and this
curve
metaphon
will draw um
enough
things in between that so that
given the thickness of the pen it'll
tend to fill in
uh
i think it gives a factor of 50
it figures the radius of these and it
chooses these points so that they
shouldn't be more than so they should
overlap and actually with a with a
little fudge factor in there so that
you've got twice as much tolerance as
you as you
uh ought to have and so only if the
curve is real wild will you have a hole
in there well so it fills in a bit this
really crude method just reduces the
filling in problem
to a sequence of the other of the other
or the other things very slow now people
have been wanting to d draw make very
sharp images so that this pen is one
pixel wide that means that i draw all of
these things over and over again it's
very very slow to fill that all in
and uh
but it's a trivial problem to fill in
between one pixel wide things you you
say to yourself that problem well the
the new metaphon is going to not use the
bit
bit representation of the raster but
it's going to use run length
representation of the raster all integer
variables
pascal doesn't have uh
convenient operations for uh
uh
for sets you can't take the intersection
of two sets or the union of two sets of
shifts the two sets the way algol w
could
i don't know why uh klaus left it out
but he did
and um so but anyway it's probably gonna
lead us to better algorithms where we
work entirely with arrays of integers uh
to represent these these patterns inside
the the memory will be able to uh get by
with uh memory that grows as order n
instead of n squared with where n is the
resolution
so the coding will will
do that and there will be some changes
to the language but i don't want the
language to get real
real baroque uh there's there's so many
more things you could do with metaphones
and you could do it with tech even so
i don't i don't plan to add uh
elaborate control structures or data
structures to meta font we're making
that will make it uh easy easier to use
uh arrays but not uh
record structures for example
um
uh
the
uh target is that that i'll be doing
that
you know winter quarter january that
i'll be working on that program
my future plan is to have three books
done that are going to be a series
called something like computer
typeography
volume one two and three
and volume one is tech volume two is
metaphon volume three is computer modern
fonts
and
that's the uh
that's
my plan is that this will be my
contribution to the
to the what i know what i've learned
about typography and i'll feel
uh justified at that point in
in
uh leaving the ball to other people to
to
see if any of those ideas are worth uh
are worth carrying on or or not and i'm
going to
write volume 4 of the art of computer
programming after volume three of
computer typography
and continue working on algorithms which
which is something i know i do well
really you had a con no you don't have a
comment
p juice
uh
if uh through meta font you generate a
few characters how immediately you can
typeset it and see because the spacing
between the latest is very important
so later design doesn't mean only
the separate letters uh but uh
how
does it really look when you put it side
by side
so when we when we design things with
meta font we have been uh uh
uh having a new mode that we've been
building into our format files called
smoke mode
and it prints out um a rather large
version of characters with corners on
them as to where we where we've
currently designed it and then you'll
have the
the character image there
and we call it smoke mode because this
is the way people um uh in the old days
would make the their fonts they would
they would uh
they would have to work of course at the
actual size with their little files and
and get the letters and then they would
take ken they would take the smoke of
the candle
and uh and then and and put it down on
the paper and try trial set until the
thing looked right so so our smoke
proofs are things that we do we don't
work at that at the real size though so
we have to have these and we put these
corners on so we can set several of them
in a row then we go back
and we look at it from from uh down the
hall as far as we can go in order to see
how it looks and until we get
something that that seems to be good
then we uh typeset uh a few words
and uh and uh make make further
corrections at that time because the eye
plays very the these these things
optically uh change when you when you
vary the scale
you have to you have to try to work at
the true size but you have to also work
at a large size when you're uh
when you're doing the design this is all
uh
another story but very interesting one
joey a uh remark on that same point
that's interesting at the merganthaller
font design group the art drawing shop
they have a useful tool for that process
you just described they keep a pair of
binoculars which they use backwards ah
so yeah in about a 20-foot room they can
get
a viewer
this is it's very important to get to be
able to see these things that that you
can't
do otherwise and uh
uh oh yes there's uh there's a there's a
uh the subtleties in font design are
are
much underappreciated by
uh
by the way by the world and uh i'm
trying to
use metaphon to capture some of those
subtleties into a program so that at
least we can see in a precise language
what they are and not just talk about
them uh by hand waving
um
the computer modern fonts are are being
uh criticized by
uh
people that i think are the best in the
world at
at these fine details and uh although i
might
i don't have the right artistic
temperament to design the most beautiful
fonts i'm at least going to have the
the hooks in there that indicate the
the right kinds of concepts and
and the uh
and
and this should help the
real artists of the world to
to
have to to to indicate what uh
what the new fonts should should include
the kind of subtleties will will be
recorded the intelligence of the font
design will be in there not just the uh
not just the drawings
that's my goal
see what happens well that's the look to
the future now uh well i'm going to take
one more comment from arthur and then
we'll have to wrap this up
it would be sometimes uh when you write
documentation uh you want to look at it
uh on uh a printed page where it's all
nicely typeset and everything
but it'll also be nice to be able to
look at it online
are there any plans for
having
the
output of tech be able to be read on a
line printer or on a
ordinary terminal
yeah well right now we have dvi
to
datadisc and dvi to uh
sun terminal working at stanford
um the
david fuchs thesis will be
on interactive versions of tech where
you see the thing immediately as you're
typing it in
and
i don't have i don't know right now if
any anybody who has
taken tech output to a line printer
uh there was an uh experiment fairly
successful of another language to line
printer in um
was it manchester i think it was and
there's a report about that in our
library i can't remember the
anstey or something you know i don't
remember the name of the
author but um
but there has but they would
set things on a few uh you had to get
used to reading the output but you could
you could you you could i mean it
somehow indicated
even on a line printer uh what the bold
and the metallic were in in a form that
people felt they had for
for approving i i find that tech users
get to um
after after a little experience they can
see in their mind what what they're
typing pretty well
it's only that they won't know how many
lines a paragraph is going it's going to
uh justify to
but they they'll
they'll uh
have a fairly good idea as they're
typing a math formula that's going to
that's going to work out all right it's
something like the
the we went to the newspaper office
uh to see the people who types at the
classified ads and they
are working with a a very primitive
terminal has only uppercase letters on
it and you ask them well wouldn't you
like to be able to see the bold face on
this uh
see things uh centered and italic and in
different fonts as they're going to
appear and they say well why we know
what it's going to look like they do
this all day long and there's no problem
they don't need that kind of feedback
but
so a user who who is the first day wants
to see
um
what what the integral sign is going to
look like and where subscripts are going
to go and things that he's typing in but
the second day you just type in and you
know it's going to be an integral i'm
going to look out all right but with
high probability you get a picture of
what that's going to be
this this
need for
for a quick
visualization
isn't any more the same as the initial
user but it's the but it you still have
it uh at the end when you're making
final polishing on a manuscript because
all of a sudden somebody's pointed out
an error on page 38
and you gotta fix that paragraph and you
want to make sure that your fix doesn't
make that paragraph any longer so that
it's not going to mess up page 39.
at that point you want an interactive
version of tech and see and you can play
with that paragraph until you got it not
only correct but also the same number of
lines as before so when i was doing
volume two
i was very heavily using our xgp
synthesizer program where i would type
set a paragraph and then i would check
it see if it was coming out okay i did
that about 20 times
at least uh for last-minute corrections
not only errors but new you know late
breaking news and things like that that
i wanted to get in the book
um
and
that so i i really believe that
this is a
a necessary thing that more software
should should be devised
to handle i also look forward to uh
programs that will
that will uh
display
modules in a web system that as you're
debugging it will just format the ones
you're you need
at the time each module is really
formatted
uh
pretty much independently of all the
other ones and self-contained unit
and
when i spend
a terrific amount of time to re to
re-weave a whole
the whole listing that's because that's
because i'm producing a thick listing
but if i'm only going to look at a few
pages of that listing then i then
selectively i could be doing only a few
parts a lot of different
software uh can be imagined that would
make such systems that we've got now
that much more powerful yeah great deal
needs to be done yet and i'm
well i'm thrilled to see so many people
listening to all these lectures uh that
that we have this experiment going now
in
in a portable
program
uh i don't know of any other instance of
of uh
where where there's going to be so many
people understanding a program of this
complexity
um so this is this is a
uh new territory and uh i think
uh
we're all in it together and uh
we should have some exciting times ahead
with that
well you have a final comment what is
this
i'm never going to be able to
on your your weave program with your
tech 82 i i just have been glancing
through it i noticed that you've managed
not to break any of your modules
on page breaks is did i miss that or uh
oh there's probably somewhere in the dvi
description where there's so many
opcodes that it does that but uh i tried
to keep modules short um
where possible but the uh but there's a
there's a ragged bottom in the weave
output and that's a there's a
easy way to do that with tech to get
ragged bottom
will be explained in the user manual
so have a good time
you